welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it's time to
kick some ice with a whole host of brand
new Batman updates though the production
of the movie is currently frozen there's
still been some cool little updates in
regards to the film from Andy Serkis and
also screenwriter Matson Tomlin
throughout this video we'll be going
through the brand new information and
giving our thoughts on it will also be
debunking the Tom Hiddleston Joker rumor
so make sure you stick around until the
end there may be some spoilers here so
if you want to go into the movie as
blind as a bat then it's time to send
yourself to the cooler because we're
going to be talking about a lot of
things that could ruin it we're also
gonna be doing some mr. freeze puns so
yeah there's that I look forward to make
sure you subscribe to the channel to
never miss an update and without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into our breakdown of the Batman
okay so Andy Serkis recently had an
exclusive interview with lad Bible in
which he went over the tone of the film
and talked about his portrayal of the
character as well as others the
interview was started by asking the
actor if fans were right to expect a
darker and broody a Batman to which he
replied I would say that's not far from
the truth it's very much about the
emotional connection between Alfred and
Bruce that's really at the center of it
and it is a really exquisite script that
matt has written so there's a lot to
unpack from that and in a video in which
we spoke to an account that had inside
knowledge in the project they stayed
that the movie would be aping a lot of
Batman earth one and in that Bruton
Alfred sort of thrust together neither
really liked one another and Alfred
never really intended to be a father
however after the death of the Wayne's
he was pretty much forced into the role
and throughout the book he has to deal
with the inner conflict over watching
his quote/unquote son going out into the
night dressed as a bat in a quest for
revenge Alfred in the book is
ex-military and he's very similar to
circus and build so I can see them
perhaps using that work as a template to
craft a new version of the character the
relationship that the two have is mended
throughout the work and Alfred becomes
more of a mentor rather than simply the
butler and Ally that we've seen in the
majority of depictions
so it's not going to be like anything
that we've seen before and circus
confirm this in the interview when
speaking about the other set played the
role he said Kane was fantastic
his alfred was legendary I couldn't even
begin to go there really you find it for
yourself it's like playing these iconic
roles in Shakespeare you go back you
revisit them and you have to make it
your own and see what it is about the
character that connects with you and
your personal Venn diagram
I was literally halfway through shooting
my part when it got shut down so it will
be interesting to see when that
resurfaces how it's been affected by it
but it is it's going to be a beautiful
film so there's a lot to take from that
and in April Matt Reeves told The
Nerdist I wanted to do not an origin
tale but a tale that would still
acknowledge his origins and that it
formed who he is like this guy he's
majorly struggling and this is how he's
trying to rise above that struggle this
very much ties in with circuses comments
on how they're pretty much reimagining
Batman and diving into the psychology of
what really makes him take I think the
darker and broody a comments highlight
that we will very much be studying Wayne
psyche and why he does what he does and
why he's just always sitting about in
the darkness brooding we're looking at
Batman there are really a lot of
contradictory things that make him a
fascinating character he locks up
criminals but does it whilst breaking
the law he dresses up as a creature of
the night similar to how his enemies
dress up in clown costumes and leotards
and overall when you think about it the
guy clearly has a lot of issues now this
is all pretty much speculation on how it
will be handled but as we know the film
is going to be centered around a murder
spree in Gotham that may or may not be
committed by the Riddler this isn't a
Batman that's fighting Superman he's not
in the Justice League stopping
Steppenwolf or chasing after the Joker
in a flashy sports car he's very much
ground-level
investigating crime scenes and seeing
the torturous acts that have been
committed by those he's trying to bring
to justice you can imagine how going out
into the night every night and finding
dead bodies that have been completely
ravaged would slowly send you insane and
due to the grounded nature of things
that we've seen so far and say the
Batmobile and Batsuit I think that the
movie will very much be sent around
Bruce slowly going off the deep end
an incredible book called Batman ego
that very much deals with this and it's
always been a side of the Dark Knight
that intrigued me sure we'd love to
imagine him like the Adam West version
in which he was shaking hands with the
mayor and going to nightclubs but what
would likely happen is that he would be
completely disheveled and at points
he may even question whether it's worth
saving the criminals that he's trying to
this is where Alfred comes in and though
it's not often stated he's pretty much
the one that keeps Bruce grounded in the
same way that Lois stops Clark from
developing a god complex and going
albright burn Alfred - stops Bruce from
becoming like the monsters that he's
trying to defeat I think that will be
very much out for its role here and in a
way he's just as much the symbol of
Batman is Bruce's he's the one who's
actually working away to care for the
character guide him and make sure that
he doesn't end up becoming a mass
criminal like those he takes down I
really hope that's the direction they go
and judging by what Reeves has said and
circus in this interview it does seem
like they're leaning towards it it was
it seems like they will be pulling from
a classic Batman property and that is
the animated series Matson Tomlin the
film screenwriter has been answering fan
questions on Twitter and he recently
gave some hints at what he looked at in
order to develop the script when
discussing what Batman IP is he pulled
from before writing it he said I can't
safely add much other than what Matt has
already put out there but I will say
that it gave me a great excuse to
re-watch the animated series and
literally triple my already heavy
comic-book collection so it does seem
like the movie might actually be pulling
from what I think is one of the most
iconic portrayals of the characters so
far Kevin Conroy and Mark Hamill pretty
much nailed their depictions and the
noir tone of the series has definitely
influenced the loved animated shows in
films in the DC EU one of the first
report on the film that we got was that
there was going to be blimps in it and
now this still remains unverified I
would personally love to see them litter
the Gotham skyline they bring so much
the city and definitely make it feel
more like Gotham the animated series as
have cause are classic and if it ends up
like that in any way I'll just be a very
happy fan and finally you may have seen
some rumors going around that Tom
Hiddleston has been cast as the Joker in
the new Batman trilogy though I can't
say for definite
whether these are true or not using
common sense it seems unlikely you may
remember that recently Johnny Depp was
rumored to be cast as the Clown Prince
of Crime but these were quickly debunked
and put on ice so the story died down
journalists still need their cliques
though so all they really done is do a
fine and replace in their articles and
change Johnny Depp to Tom Hiddleston now
why I don't think that this is true in
the slightest is because the actor is
currently playing Loki in the MCU and
he's even starring in an upcoming Disney
Plus series centered solely on the
character we don't know the ins and outs
of these contracts as they're never
released to the public
but I can imagine that there would be
stipulations in there that say if an
actor is leading a property then they
were unable to sign on as any other
comic book characters when this argument
is brought up Josh Brolin always comes
up with it due to his depiction of
Thanos and cable however he was never
really heading up a franchise or a
property himself so it's unlikely that
these restrictions were fully in place
what I do think will happen is that this
rumor will pick up a lot of steam
similar to the Johnny Depp one and then
it will be shot down once it gets big
enough and so the people that cover this
will just insert a new actor I think
people just need to chill when these
things pop up because it's so easy to
just make these things up you look at
any site like we got this covered and
they can easily run a story like Chris
Evans's and talks to return to the MCU
reportedly and it's exactly that he is
reportedly in talks to return because
they're reporting on it that's like me
saying definition has the best ice puns
reportedly sure he's a cool guy but we
know that's not true
reportedly so yeah I doubt this is the
case and once this cools down you'll see
it was nothing but an icebreaker anyway
that's all of the Batman news for the
week
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on these updates and what you want to
see in the future I'm gonna be keeping
my eyes closed the updates and if any
big news comes out then you'll
definitely be the first to hear it
make sure you stay a lock to the channel
and also please give us a thumbs up if
you enjoyed the video if you want
something else to watch that makes you
check out our breakdown of the original
Batman V Superman script
she's gonna be linked at the end we read
the entire thing and there's a lot to
talk about in regards to it so
definitely head over to that after this
if you want to support the channel
rumors let this ninety-nine cents a
month then please click the join button
below you access to content early and
can also suggest video topics and
breakdowns we massively appreciate you
and it goes a long way to helping videos
like this get made if you want to come
chat to us after the show either follow
us at Definition YT or click the discord
link in the description below those the
best ways to keep it today with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best I'll see you next
time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]